brewers on the cardinals game two in
this twinite doubleheader crew trying
for a sweep
behind corbin burns two on with two outs
for paul deyoung
two on
the pitch
swinging and a fly ball
to shallow right and it is going to be
caught by jericho to end the other you
got daniel ponce de leon going for the
cardinals in the nightcap and uh he's
got great stuff we know that we've seen
success in the past but he's been
struggling this year and yelich drops
down from two to three in the lineup for
the nightcap two and two and ponce de
leon is trying to close the window here
on yelich
and the brewers swing and a miss a
fastball away strikes him out potts de
leon struck out the side garcia hira and
yelich we go to the second nothing
nothing in milwaukee
well now eight of the ten innings have
seen a runner reach base can the offense
get it going lane thomas
jimin around burns deals
got him looking
on the outside corner
88 on that
cutter or slider that looked like a
slider right there got him looking he
strikes out the side put two away
here's jed jerko the pitch right down
the middle strike three called the 94
mile an hour fastball and jerko wasn't
looking for it
five strikeouts with six batters in a
row retired by ponce de leon
so it's first and second with nobody out
for paul goldschmidt
2-2
struck him out
threw him a cutter down and away and he
gets a huge strike out of paul
goldschmidt
and now it's miller
two on and one out
one two to miller
he waved at it missed it nottingham
blocked it but not before runners
advance to second and third
so it's up to paul deyoung
he was batting with two runners aboard
in the first inning and he popped out to
jerko
two and two with two outs
the pitch
fly ball playable in right
braun coming in he's calling for it and
he's got it and the inning is over
no runs one hit two left for st louis
bottom of the third is next no score
hero with one swing in the back could
make this a really big lead
and the o2 pitch here comes swing and a
miss he struck him out there's some
noise for you he strikes out hiro for
the second time
and that is now six strikeouts for
daniel ponce de leon
carpenter
struck out in the second inning it was a
called third strike
payoff pitch
struck him out swinging
cutter over the outside corner and
carpenter's gone strikeout number seven
for corbin burns
so colton wong will have to come through
10 rbis for colton this year hitting
269.
the 1-2
struck him out with a breaking ball
nottingham blocks applies the tag and
burns wiggles through trouble in the
fourth
no runs a hit and error and two left for
saint louis
halfway through
we are nodded nothing nothing and it
will be yelich braun and vogelback to
face
the right-hander daniel ponce de leon
who's trying to win for the first time
in 2020
next pitch swing and a miss he strikes
out yellidge
there's brawn
big rbi double in the eighth inning of
game one two two pitch
swing and a miss he chased the high
fastball that one up around shoulder
high
that's strikeout number eight for ponce
de leon
jed jerko will bat with two outs
vogel back at first
jericho high fly deep left center field
o'neal watching two nothing brewers
jed jerkle off the bat hits a two run
shot his eighth of the year
and the crew jumps out in front
and now luis urias
next pitch check swing did he go yes he
did
ponce strikes out
paul goldschmidt
the tying run at the plate as the
cardinals bat in the fifth inning
the 2-2
struck him out with a slider
goldschmidt gone on strikes punch out
number nine for corbin burns
and brad miller will hit for the third
time he has walked in struck out the
pitch runner starts and stops a swing in
the miss by miller and the bases are
loaded
for tyler o'neill
they play o'neill to pull three brewers
on the left side of the infield and the
one-two pitch to tyler is hit on the
ground on the left side slow roller it's
going to be a tough play late throw to
first he's safe he beat it out and the
cardinals get on the board that infield
hit
for tyler o'neill scores tommy edmond
and it's now 2-1
milwaukee we'll take that
and the line continues for matt wieder's
fly ball
left center playable for yelich just
short of the warning track
and weeders flies out with the bases
loaded in the inning claudio preserves
the lead but barely
cardinals get a run on two hits and
strand three
and now brad miller is up there and a
good time to do something as miller has
been on base once that was a first
inning walk in game two tonight after
going over three with three strikeouts
in the opener here's the next pitch and
a swing and a base set to left field
here's goldsmith coming around third
base he's trying to score the throw to
the plate too late tie ball game
wieners
a couple of singles he's single to right
single to center and then flied out
two-two tie the pitch
check swing and a bouncer to
short the throw in time and
no further damage and ben gemmell is
coming on now
to bat for nottingham
the pitch to the left-handed banner
fastball a swing and a mess he got him
runner at third two down and paul de
young is up the pitch
and there's a hot shot base hit to left
field edmond scores and the cardinals
lead 3-2 in the ninth
so now it's up to jace peterson
paul to young with a go-ahead rbi with
two outscoring tommy edmond the pitch
a swing and a mass a red bird winner a
curveball strikes out peterson and this
ball game has come to an end